[Musica]
stiamo per partire per un pianeta nuovo
per un pianeta fuori dal sistema solare
un sistema un pianeta che
è simile alla terra e questa è la prima
spedizione che
costituirà poi il primo insediamento
umano su questa nuova pianeta
immaginate quanti aspetti sono dovuti
sono stati considerati
per preparare questa spedizione ma oggi
ci concentreremo sul sul cibo su Quale
sistema alimentare portare su questo
nuovo pianeta un sistema alimentare è il
modo in cui il cibo è prodotto
trasformato distribuito e consumato
la domanda ci ha messo immediatamente di
fronte a una scelta duale che facciamo
ripercorriamo la via più semplice che
utilizziamo in gran parte sulla terra
ovvero ricreando sul nuovo pianeta un
sistema di consumo di massa che
porta poi allo sfruttamento
indiscriminato le risorse oppure oppure
fondiamo un sistema basato sull'economia
circolare
come ormai scienza istituzioni e
cittadini stanno promuovendo stanno
chiedendo
In sostanza
vogliamo comportarci da
predatori o da custodi
e naturalmente noi scegliamo di partire
con questo secondo con questo secondo
scopo portando poi sul nuovo pianeta
quindi un un
sistema circolare nel quale le tre fasi
interconnesse di produzione consumo
gestione dei rifiuti sono concepite in
modo da da
produrre soltanto il cibo strettamente
necessario
e valorizzando anche il surplus che
diventa diventa una risorsa
la chiave di questa scelta è considerare
il cibo come un bene comune che non sia
soggetto alle logiche del profitto
queste logiche hanno una caratteristica
predatoria tipica poi delle attività
delle grandi Industrie Alimentari che
sfruttano le risorse di un territorio i
suoi abitanti fino a quando poi queste
risorse non si esauriscano per poi
passare a un altro luogo e non a caso
vengono chiamate aziende locusta queste
le pratiche di questo sistema alimentare
che è un sistema lineare produzione
consumo rifiuto
sono legati poi all'introduzione di
monoculture che prosciugano la le
risorse naturali distruggono la
biodiversità
necessitano di lunghi trasferimenti per
distribuire i prodotti e poi lasciano le
comunità in balia di un'unica fonte di
reddito
il sistema che noi vogliamo sviluppare
invece si basa su un'agricoltura
diversificata rispettosa dell'ambiente
rispettosa delle stagioni e che
retribuisca equamente il lavoro
in maniera tale
da assicurare cibo sano per tutti e che
diventa un diritto fondamentale
universale il concetto quella
sostenibilità come dice la Fao un
sistema sostenibile è quello in cui
si assicura ci vorranno per tutti
senza che vengano compromesse le basi
economiche e sociali ambientali che
garantiscono questo diritto anche alle
generazioni future
le tecniche poi di produzione che
supportano questo le conosciamo Sono già
praticate sulla terra e sono hanno
dimostrato anche la loro la loro
efficacia l'agricoltura biologica
l'allevamento all'aperto non intensivo
le filiere distribuite Corte gli esempi
che ci sono ormai a giro di piccola
distribuzione organizzata
la
nostra visione È chiaramente una visione
globale deve tenere conto
dell'interco sistema del pianeta di
tutti i suoi abitanti quelli che stanno
partendo ora e quelli che verranno in
futuro però abbiamo pensato di
realizzarlo tramite una suddivisione in
sottosistemi connessi tra loro solidali
tra loro che stimolino la crescita la
nascita di comunità locali che si
sviluppano proprio intorno al sistema
alimentare e su questo concetto del
locale poi poi
ci ritorniamo in
seguito
nei primi tempi chiaramente i cibi le
diete saranno quelli che ci stiamo
portando che ci stiamo portando
sull'astronave della terra Ma poi
pensiamo che in breve
le comunità evolvono in maniera autonoma
vuoi per
le specificità dei territori il clima la
scoperta di nuovi di nuovi di nuove
fonti di alimentazione
e cucinare sul nostro pianeta
sarà un frutto di ricerca
sperimentazione contaminazione
sull'astronave ci sono già chef
dietologi nutrizionisti con noi perché
poi anche le cucine che noi riteniamo
tradizionali
si sono evoluti accogliendo integrando
le novità si tratta di un processo
culturale no E come qualsiasi processo
culturale evolve quando
si contamina e si confronta con il nuovo
tra poi i produttori gli abitanti delle
varie comunità dovrà avvenire
solidalmente un trasferimento di pratica
di conoscenze in modo che i progressi
abbiano di nuovo la dimensione globale
i produttori agricoli una parola su di
loro perché avranno un
[Musica]
compito fondamentale che è quello della
della
custodia dei semi che sono la garanzia
della continuità Delle specie vegetali
l'accesso il
lo scambio dei semi dovrà avvenire in
maniera libera che non sia sottoposta a
privatizzazione venivate brevetti
abbiamo ora parlato di come organizzare
il sistema alimentare
parliamo di cosa mangeremo sul nuovo
pianeta Quale sarà la dieta la dieta è
comprende elementi basilari proteine
carboidrati Grassi fibre e poi in modo
in cui Questi elementi si combinano tra
loro che fa di una dieta una salubre no
salutare
la dieta mediterranea è quello che noi
abbiamo preso come riferimento
povera di grassi animali ricca di
elementi vegetali
e questa è stata dichiarata dall'unesco
nel 2010 patrimonio e materiale
dell'umanità in questo patrimonio
ce lo vogliamo portare con noi sul nuovo
pianeta
Tra l'altro poi è acclarato quei
vantaggi di una dieta non mantengono
soltanto alla dimensione personale
alla salute della persona ma hanno
riflessi forti sulla collettività
termini per esempio di salute pubblica
sull'ambiente
la malnutrizione che ormai è
che si diciamo che si
coniuga con denutrizione ma anche come
sovralimentazione come cattiva
alimentazione ormai nelle statistiche
una delle maggiori cause di malattie
pensate che ha superato fumo alcol in
questo
e poi altrettanto dimostrato che la
produzione del cibo è uno dei fattori
scatenanti
principali del cambiamento climatico a
causa delle missioni di gas serra della
perdita di biodiversità ancora una volta
del consumo di acqua e dell'inquinamento
di acqua e di terra e del terreno
e
spesso le diete Vengono prese come
modello non soltanto per la loro
componente di salutare ma anche per
implicazioni sociali culturali la dieta
mediterranea accanto a semplici buoni
offre anche nell'immaginario il piacere
della convivialità della condivisione
pensiamo subito a una tavolata
all'aperto con persone che mangiano
ridono
parlano con il piacere di stare a tavola
insieme proprio convivialità
condivisione sono per noi fattori di
grado di creare una sensibilità comune
una coscienza diffusa che faciliti la
transizione verso il sistema un sistema
sostenibile
e A questo proposito Tra l'altro ancora
la Fao ha dichiarato nel nel 2012 la
dieta mediterranea è lo stile di vita
più sostenibile sul pianeta Ecco perché
l'abbiamo preso a riferimento
la dieta quindi è un mezzo per
conseguire un cambiamento perché di pari
passo con l'introduzione di nuove norme
è fondamentale che si adottino strategie
per coinvolgere i cittadini di buone
pratiche che poi sono volte a
sensibilizzare i comportamenti che
sfociano poi nelle abitudini quotidiane
l'importante però anche in questo caso è
rendersi conto della Dimensione globale
cioè che è necessario che i cambiamenti
delle regole
delle abitudini delle pratiche avvengano
collettivamente e non soltanto
individualmente
una delle attività che ci mantengono in
vita oltre che darci piacere
naturalmente è mangiare
acquistiamo il cibo lo prepariamo lo
consumiamo più volte al giorno questo fa
parte della nostra
routine quotidiana che spesso seguiamo
senza neanche porci troppa attenzione Ma
se noi Secondo noi
il rapporto giusto corretto col cibo e
quello nel quale sia una visione
consapevole di tutto il ciclo di come
viene prodotto trasformato distribuito è
essenziale quindi che l'abitante del
nuovo pianeta abbia un rapporto diretto
con il sistema alimentare Ecco perché le
comunità devono avere una dimensione
piccola locale
quindi che sia sempre consapevole della
provenienza di ciò che mangia e che
possa partecipare attivamente a questo
processo apprendendone Tra l'altro il
giusto valore questo anche per limitare
gli sprechi perché gli sprechi
specialmente nel diciamo nelle nei paesi
ricchi avvengono in gran parte a casa
nostra nelle nostre cucine e il costo è
enorme non soltanto perché si devono
gestire i rifiuti ma anche a Monte per
la terra l'acqua l'energia il lavoro che
sono stati utilizzati per produrre il
cibo che poi va da sprecare
e le forme di partecipazione che noi
intendiamo prendere come modello ci sono
già sono nate dal basso sono forme di
partecipazione che per esempio conducono
l'acquisto diretto con dai produttori
gruppi di acquisto solidale o nei
mercati di vendita diretta
la partecipazione diretta alla
produzione al lavoro nei campi Gli orti
sociali gli Orti Urbani le comunità a
supporto dell'Agricoltura poi tutte le
forme di
più evolute No più organizzate come la
co-produzione il pre finanziamento
e siamo alla partenza siamo dunque al
conto alla rovescia si scaldano i motori
e iniziavano avventura da zero con le
idee con le convinzioni che abbiamo
fatto nostre anche osservando gli errori
compiuti errori che sono sembrano
impossibili da rimuovere anche se tutti
Ormai siamo concordi sul fatto che il
sistema attuale vada cambiato
sulla scaletta che porta su nella
navicella Vi chiedo quindi se possiamo
fare qualcosa qui sulla terra perché il
modello che noi ci siamo immaginati per
il nuovo il nuovo pianeta può essere
realizzato qui da noi
vi dico che anche che il cambiamento
passa dai nostri comportamenti
quotidiani
che le scelte individuali però che
inserisca che si inseriscono in un
contesto nel quale la consapevolezza
si estende si diffonde in tutta la
comunità hanno un potere che non abbiamo
ancora
ben compreso ben concepito e che però
Vale la pena di esplorare
le molteplici domande a cui dare una
risposta sono anche una responsabilità
nostra di noi cittadini di noi
consumatori che siamo parte integrante
del sistema alimentare
Dove dove è giusto che io faccia la
spesa
quali produttori quali intermediari sono
quelli che appartengono a un sistema
virtuoso che io voglio finanziare
acquistando i loro prodotti Quali sono
le abitudini che io voglio cambiare e
come posso poi in una comunità sempre
più grande arrivare a condizionare certe
scelte globali Infine come possiamo
rendere un cibo sano un diritto
veramente universale un diritto di tutti
E allora mi rendo conto che c'è da fare
ancora qui sulla Terra forse più che sul
pianeta sul nuovo pianeta e che ho
voglia di provarci e che è giusto farlo
allora
Allora scendo dalla scaletta mi sfilo la
tuta mi tolgo il casco e rimango sulla
terra grazie